تحول الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد من مصدر
صداع لموسكو الى ضغط نفسي على الجيش
الاوكراني فقدان السيطره على الاجواء جعل
مهمه نقل الاسلحه الغربيه الثقيله الى
الداخل الاوكراني مهمه صعبه مواجهه التحدي
تحصلت اوكرانيا على العديد من انظمه
الدفاع الغربيه الا ان اهمها يبقى نظام
باتريت بعيد المدى وهو عماد الدفاع الجوي
الامريكي الذي بات يواجه للمره الاولى
ظروف حرب حقيقيه تضررت المنظومه قبل ايام
بضربات الروسيه فكيف تم الامر
بالقربي من مطاري كيا بالدولي نصب نظام
كاتريت بهدف توفير دفاع بعيد المدى يغطي
كل مناطق كياب ومن اجل توفير دفاع طبقي
متماسك وضعت انظمه ليوبارد فلاك بانزر
قصيره المدى انظمه القديمه لكنها حل
اقتصادي لحمايه باتريا باهظه الثمن من
هجوم الخيرات باتريوت ومنذ دخوله اوكرانيا
تحول الى هدف موسكو الاول وبدون تحديده لن
تتمكن من استخدام الصواريخ والمسيرات غير
المكلفه التي تستنزف دفاعات اوكرانيا
صواريخ باتريا يتصل سرعتها الى 3 ماخ اي
ثلاث مرات السرعه الصوت واذا ما استثنينا
صاروخ اسكندر الذي لا يصل مداه كيب فلم
يبقى في طرسانه موسكو الا كنجال الذي تصل
سرعته لعشر ماخ ثلاث مرات اسرع من صواريخ
باتريوت عدم القدره على اعتراض فاتريه
ليكنجال لا يعني عدم رصده في الرادار طاقم
الباتريوت تعرف عليه من خلال دراسه سرعته
لكن وقت وصوله للهدف لن يتعدى دقيقه واحده
وهو زمن لا يكفي لتغيير موقع باتريوت وهنا
قرر الطاقم المشغل اطلاق كل الصواريخ في
الفراغ سته وثلاثون صاروخا في المجموع
بهدف تخفيف قوه الانفجار ومنع امتداده
للبطاريات الاخرى ثوان بعدها واصل كنجال
الى هدفه وسقط بين الرادار واحدى
البطاريات واشنطن لم تنفي تضرر باتري لاول
مره في حرب حقيقيه لكن روسيا اضطرت
لاستخدام صاروخها الاغلى وبذلك دخلت موسكو
وواشنطن مرحله اخرى من حرب الاستنزاف
والمكان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات